oh god oh no make sure you're filming
that those fools they couldn't handle it
i was gonna live in days and the media
didn't know what to do look
are bad bro there was just like a lot of
attention this all season so yeah we
started a hype house
he could be mvp
you could be mvp
cowboy's here for a usual hype oh sorry
my elder dudes but like are you really
still going for in your side
[Music]
the 2022 gridiron high tide house was
the place to be you had the rams the
chiefs and drag outfits specifically but
no one else on the falcons uh hi i'm
kyle is there anything you want me to do
around the house i can cook pipe house
was classic media and not the good kind
of media where you talk uncontested to a
podcaster and a tank top but the bad
kind where they hurt your feelings do
you even know what tic tac is my
favorite show is church mine too you let
trey lansin but he's barely played hey
kid think you'll have a breakout year
trey lance says yes who's paying for all
of this sponsors and then they made a
gargantuan mistake they started hyping
up an nfc east team that feeling when
people are high on the eagles for some
reason hi i'm a bearded fantasy
podcaster and look we were just hyping
anybody pretty sure i made up bruce hall
javonte it's russ man this is ridiculous
i dressed up for this i wore my own
jersey but as you learn playing for the
bills some things are just out of your
control and life's not fair do you think
there's any one person to blame for what
happened
time
sure yeah i said what i said yo everyone
listen wait tyrique doom tua is like in
my homes and brady had a baby raised by
a jugs machine
as i've learned very occasionally in my
career there are some things you just
can't say so what happened was the
literal weight of expectations got too
heavy broncos country
i tried
[Music]
trey lance says the game has really
slowed down for him and credits the
coaching staff for his development
triland says he actually likes jimmy
staying and breathing down his neck
trae lance also says the falcon super
bowl loss was a personnel failure and
not related to play calling in any way